una muestra de fuerza en la víspera de
un debate fundamental en el senado los
manifestantes tomaron las calles de
buenos aires- llamando a los
legisladores a rechazar la reforma legal
que legalizaría la interrupción del
embarazo un proyecto que fue aprobado
casi tres semanas antes por la cámara
baja del congreso esta ley va contra el
sentido común contra la ley natural
contra la misma razón sería un
avasallamiento de justamente de la misma
constitución nacional que defiende y
entiende que los derechos del niño y
cuando reconoce los derechos del niño
los reconoce desde el primer instante de
la concepción el proyecto ley
legalizaría el aborto hasta la semana 14
del embarazo y convertiría a argentina
en el país más grande de latinoamérica
en consagrar este derecho
la legislación cuenta con el apoyo del
presidente alberto fernández y con el de
cada vez más grupos feministas que están
planeando movilizarse este martes para
el debate pero
se espera que la votación en el senado
sea ajustada en un país en el que la
influencia de la iglesia católica es muy
fuerte la cámara alta rechazó una ley
similar en 2018 con el presidente macri
manteniéndose al margen del debate esta
vez los propulsores esperan que el nuevo
gobierno y su mayoría en el parlamento
sean suficiente para que argentina haga
historia